c'est quoi le premier truc que tu as
fait quand tu es revenu oh série mes
proches dans mes bras c'est vraiment ce
qui m'a le plus manqué c'est ma famille
adore non même pas Étienne du coup je
savais que si je devais énormément d'eau
je pouvais combler ma faim donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai pas été frustré par la
nourriture l'hygiène c'est comment
là-bas on a rien il y avait rien mais
les brosses à dents pas de brosse non
pas de brosse à dents parce que moi je
me brosser les dents
moi je pense à lui
pour le ramadan déjà on est pas bien tu
vois non je sais mais au final je pense
qu'on s'habitue l'humain s'habitue à
tout à ne pas manger à être sale c'est
pas ton haleine non vraiment pas je
pense que tout le monde sentait mauvais
on y pense même pas déjà quand on mange
pas 0 quoi vraiment même le premier jour
on se dit pas ouais
peut-être le premier jour on peut se
dire ah lui il est pas mal déjà sinon
mais rien à très vite on s'en fout en
fait pour